all right yeah i think we uh we found
the zodiac killer
well
i'm not keeping my contacts in plain
english
best quality vacuum
hey guys pete here there was a point in
the first two episodes of better call
saul's final season where it got hard to
imagine a way out for nacho no matter
how much you wanted things to turn out
differently a happy ending was hard to
imagine after the sixth episode this
week i'm starting to feel the same way
about kim the episode turned out to be
the final installment in the setup
trilogy that's been unfolding over the
past few weeks and ended with a point of
no return moment a literal u-turn
towards a terrible choice and it feels
like there will be consequences i'll get
into how we got there and what it all
might mean after this quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched better
call saul season 6 episode 6 yet then
this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
in axe to grind there's a long shot of a
young kim wexler through the passenger
window of her mother's car as it drives
away from a close call her mother has
just told her to relax you got away with
it but it doesn't look like she's able
to do that while she's internalizing
what just happened on the one hand she
was just saved from getting in trouble
and even got to keep the earrings she
was trying to steal after her mom
resnatched them on the way out these are
earrings that were instantly
recognizable as something she wears as
an adult even to someone like me who
doesn't pay a lot of attention to
jewelry on the other hand as was pointed
out in the flashback to nebraska last
season this is not a happy childhood for
the future attorney because her past has
been a mystery to us the line that her
mom delivers i didn't know you had it in
you is an idea that seems to keep
emerging in her story jimmy didn't think
she had it in her to follow through to
take down her old boss at hhm howard
didn't think she had it in her to walk
away from schweikern and coakley on her
own and is currently oblivious to her
involvement in what's happening to him
and as viewers it would have been hard
for us to imagine that she had it in her
to turn down this offer she's presented
with by cliff main in this episode it
makes me want to imagine there's one
more i didn't know you had it in you
that relates to her getting out of this
unskate but it's getting harder to
imagine how that might happen and we'll
definitely be coming back to that as far
as their plans concerned while it's
never spelled out directly i do think we
can put it together based on what we see
in this episode and as far as their
victim he does still use the kitchen in
his lovely looking house but is
currently residing in the guest house
along with his wardrobe he's doing his
best to get along with his wife who we
meet for the first time but their
conversation says that things might be
worse than we thought from his remarks
at the therapist you watch him craft an
amazing looking cup of coffee that
includes a peace sign in the foam and
the way cheryl dumps it into her travel
cup without an acknowledgement or even
cleaning up the mess she makes pretty
much says it all she doesn't seem very
interested in what he tells her about
jimmy or very convinced that he'll take
care of it and she doesn't even say
goodbye on her way out it's all pretty
harsh and it all kind of reinforces this
idea that he doesn't deserve what's
happening and it'll add to the impact
when their plan plays out at the office
he gets a detailed report of all of
jimmy's comings and goings from his
private investigator the only thing out
of place is a trip to the bank to
withdraw what looks like twenty thousand
dollars in cash howard believes he's
catching jimmy in the middle of
something here since there's no legal
reason for him to be doing that but
we'll get confirmation later that this
is all part of their plan which also
includes a trip to see the shady
veterinarian caldera or maybe it's more
accurate to say that he's shady and a
veterinarian because honestly he seems
to be pretty solid as far as taking care
of animals is concerned
they go to him for a drug that will
dilate howard's pupils and presumably
make him look coked out during this
mediation session for the sandpiper case
this corresponds with the call that
jimmy has francesca make later to hhm so
that they can get access to listen in
this is the big event the culmination of
their plan that they've taken to calling
d-day and if it works howard's
reputation will be called into question
in front of all of these important
people and they'll have to settle the
case caldera assures them that it won't
show up in any drug screens and he seems
confident that it's safe the one thing
he mentions that might turn out to be
important though is that the effect is
dependent on the person's tolerance for
caffeine and in the earlier scene where
howard's making the cup of coffee for
his wife you notice that even though
they have this really great espresso
maker which he's very good at operating
he actually takes tea so that might be
something to keep in the back of our
minds the vet also mentions that he's on
his way out of the business of being the
guy you come to when you need something
like this when you need to connect with
a criminal he just needs to sell his
black book and then he's leaving town
jimmy can't believe that he would walk
away from this great nearly passive
income stream but kim says he knows what
he wants which i guess is her
recognizing herself and him but also we
don't actually see how it goes down but
this book does show up inside saul's
house in the episode 1 opening teaser
also in case you missed it ed the
disappears card is inside and kim looks
at it we know he'll play an important
role in the creation of gene but we're
gonna have to wait to find out how they
come to be in possession of the black
book in the card the last part of the
plan is to fake some photographs of saul
passing the twenty thousand dollars off
to an actor who looks like the retired
judge who kim found out was handling the
mediation from viola they bring in the
film students they put all that together
and everything looks like it's going to
go off perfectly until jimmy goes to buy
a celebratory bottle of zafiro anejo at
the liquor store there he runs into the
actual judge and notices that he has a
broken arm jimmy thinks they need to
abort because now the photographs won't
be convincing and at this stage kim
should be able to let it go because the
other thing that happened for her this
episode is that deal with cliff i
mentioned earlier he came to see her in
action in one of her pro bono cases she
was making a great argument to get
evidence thrown out because the
arresting officer used a flimsy excuse
for probable cause and during that we
got a what seems to be unrelated
reminder of jeff the cab driver's air
freshener from the season 4 gene scene
after cliff checked on how she left
things with howard where she told him
that she owes him a lot he explains
there's an opportunity where a major
source of funding for justice reform
programs is expanding to the southwest
she would still have to go to a meeting
and convince them but cliff thinks she's
a lock and that she would probably get
the funding she needs to do what she
wants for her pro bono practice she's
excited jimmy is maybe even more excited
and the only catch was that the meeting
was happening on d-day jimmy assured her
that she didn't need to be there and
this is a ticket to her dream anyway if
this goes through they don't need the
sandpiper money and that's why it's hard
to understand her decision she was
already on her way when he made the call
about the judge having the cast he gave
her the out of saying they should just
live to fight another day and still
after some thought she says it happens
today and makes the turn back to see
this plan through the way it was
presented it doesn't sound like she'll
get a second chance at a meeting and we
have to imagine that she thought of this
while she was making that decision if
she keeps going she gets what she wants
by doing the right thing and i describe
this as a point of no return because
this was her chance to go the other way
if she just keeps driving she's got a
promising career doing good for the less
fortunate and even if that falls through
she's got a husband that loves her and
is supportive when she makes the turn
she's putting all of that at risk and
putting everything she has into pulling
off this scam to basically get the same
things only in this version howard looks
ridiculous
it's frustrating but it's also
fascinating it's hard to watch but i
can't look away in the video i did about
their motivations i touched on the idea
of her being driven by something deeper
to play with the episode's title she
definitely has an axe to grind i don't
know that the opening sequence clears
that up it does add another layer and of
course people are complicated i feel
like it makes some sense about why she's
drawn to jimmy and how she handled
situations in earlier seasons more than
anything though it just makes it feel
like we're at the place where it's all
or nothing and i don't know what will
happen next but won't likely stop
thinking about it until we find out
there were also some other things that
happened in this episode francesca went
wild decorating the strip mall office
she's got a flare for a vibe that's
professional and refined and you know
inviting it's funny that there's
probably a connection to the way both
the furnishings and her disposition
changed to match what they're like in
breaking bad we didn't get any gus
sightings in this episode which might be
related to the fact that giancarlo
esposito did a pretty good job directing
it but we did get some time with mike he
got a call about using resources to
protect stacy and kaylee and made it
clear that he wouldn't be backing down
from that when he talked to tyrus this
might have been a little superfluous but
i thought it worked pretty well it
pointed out how difficult this situation
is this is across the board for gus's
whole organization more or less and also
to show how dedicated mike is and i
thought that made sense considering the
last thing we have to talk about showed
how dedicated lalo is he's still in
germany he made his way to the remote
house that casper's living in he found
out where that was by going to talk to
the people who made the slide rule
memorial for him in case you forgot he
was the worker who told mike that werner
was worth 50 of him before he returned
to germany he wasn't expecting any
visitors and decides to run and hide
whenever he sees this man come into his
backyard through the forest that part of
his plan wasn't all that bad he does end
up getting the jump on his pursuer when
he follows him inside a barn the only
problem was that he decided to hit him
with the back of his axe instead of just
killing him unfortunately lalo isn't the
kind of guy you want to have a
conversation with under these
circumstances and after tony dalton does
a really great job of convincing me he
can barely breathe he uses a concealed
razor to slash casper then takes the
opportunity to use his axe to cut off
his foot lalo gives him his belt to stop
the bleeding so he can ask him what gus
was building and then i imagine he'll
put him out of his misery before he
leaves and with that we've made it
through the setup and now we'll get to
see if the payoff was worth it
i like this episode a lot better than
last week's it was mostly the same but
we were able to put together what was
happening with the plan last week it
seemed like they were teasing us a
little bit not really giving us details
and this time they didn't come out and
tell us but they gave us everything we
needed to put it together they're going
to use the pi who i'm not sure is in on
this or not but he's giving howard this
information and they let him think that
he found something so when he sees these
photographs he's gonna think that
jimmy's trying to bribe the judge and
after they give him the drug to make it
look like he's really high he's going to
make a baseless allegation jimmy will be
able to call in and listen to it all go
down and it did seem like if it plays
out that way it would work i really
enjoyed the flashback and thought it was
impressive how much they managed to
flesh things out in that five minute
sequence the actors who play young kim
and her mom do a fantastic job of
resembling ray seahorn and matching some
of her mannerisms and the little touches
like her nervously bouncing her foot and
still wearing those earrings are fun
it's also interesting to compare this to
season 5's flashback in that kim
wouldn't take the ride home with her mom
who was late because she'd been drinking
she was willing to walk miles carrying a
cello to stand by her principles in this
one she's showing that she does indeed
have it in her and also that she's
willing to accept her mother's help when
she needs it and possibly because she
wants something she can be surprising
and that's something we've seen in small
moments throughout the series the show's
been about jimmy mcgill transforming
into salt goodman and since it's a
prequel to breaking bad and we know him
in that show it's natural to make
comparisons between his transformation
and walter white's now you can't help
but think of making the same comparisons
with kim there's the idea of did
situations that came up create the
character or did it cause who they
really are to come out and when you look
at all three i think you come up with
different answers i thought the d-day
and omaha beach references were pretty
interesting too that was a successful
mission but a lot of soldiers lost their
lives in service of that i think it's
safe to say that there's going to be
casualties with their plan as well and
if kim and jimmy are worried about that
they probably should have chose a
different name there was a lot of good
breaking bad references here and it was
nice to see caldera come back i thought
it looked really good and i thought
there was some great editing in this one
i really like the cut from jimmy and kim
celebrating the casper's axe chopping
wood and then to the laundry from jimmy
holding the client who was peeing in his
water feature the mid-season finale is
next it genuinely feels like things
won't be the same after this next
episode and i think that that's probably
a good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you thought about
this episode what you think about what's
gonna happen next and what you think it
all will mean about the second half of
the season when it comes back and join
us for the live stream at 9 00 pm
eastern time on tuesday so we can dig a
little bit deeper please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon